MEGAN LACY: I
started at Hillsdale
when I was 16 years old.
I think that's one of the
reasons my parents were
pleased to have me at a
small school close to home.
Everyone at
Hillsdale immediately
is overwhelmingly
kind and welcoming,
and it's a family atmosphere
from the beginning.
And so I think
that it's probably
one of the few colleges
I could have gone to
at that time that would
have felt so safe.
I studied a lot in college.
I think I might have
studied more in college
than I did in law school.
I grew up figure
skating competitively,
and so I trained
like a full time job.
And I think that it was kind
of natural to approach college
with a similar attitude that if
you're going to do something,
you do it seriously.
I'm grateful for that attitude.
I'm grateful to my
parents for putting up
with all of that growing up.
I think it was a gift to me.
I was a Kappa,
which was great fun.
Several of my sorority
sisters remain dear friends
to this day.
After law school, I clerked
for two federal judges,
one on a federal
district court and one
on the United States Court of
Appeals for the Ninth Circuit.
When Justice Kavanaugh
was nominated,
I went to work in the White
House Counsel's office
to assist them.
I spent a lot of time
with the justice,
and I was delighted
when he asked
if I would be
interested in working
for him at the court
after his confirmation.
Clerking at the Supreme
Court is an incredible honor.
It is a dream for
many law students.
It was for me.
There are only a
few dozen people
who get to do it every year.
Hillsdale is a very special
place to spend four years.
I would tell students to
appreciate the gift that they
have and the education
that they're being offered.
It is rare.
Take advantage of
your professors.
Take advantage of the
community and the friendships
that you can build at the
school, and work hard.
Don't take it for granted
is what I would say.